Film Courage: Why is screenwriting hard?
Markus Redmond, Actor/Writer/Director/Producer:
It’s not.
Film Courage: Should we ask Siri?
Markus: It’s not.
Anything is hard that you are forcing.
If you’re forcing it, it’s hard.
Film Courage: Then maybe it’s the career
aspect that’s hard?
So the screenwriting process is easy?
Markus: Oh yeah.
The navigating of a career is always most
challenging then doing the actual thing.
Like there are tons of incredibly talented
actors that are not stars for one reason or
another that has nothing to do with how talented
they are as actors.
It’s the same thing with writers, directors,
musicians, songwriters.
A career trajectory is a completely different
skillset.
That’s why it’s important to either have
someone who can guide you through it or figure
out how to market stuff so that to appeals
to the people you are trying to get it to.
But yes, I said earlier, it’s way easy to
write the script than pitch it.
They will ask you for like a logline.
That’s a few words.
It takes me forever to figure it out.
But you want a 100 pages of a script?
Done!
Easy!
Gotcha!
Now you want me to take those 100 pages and
put them in a sentence?
Why?
I’ve got a 100 pages you know?
So they are just different skillsets but I
don’t necessarily think it’s hard.
It can be challenging, it can be difficult.
There could be research involved.
It’s not necessarily easy but I wouldn’t
categorize it as hard unless you are forcing
it or there are forces impeding on the creative
flow necessary.
Film Courage: So were there times where you
had some who wanted to (quote) “guide your
career” and sometimes it’s better to go
it alone?
Markus: Yes.
Film Courage: Someone that saw things in you
and thought “This will be great.
Let’s work together on the trajectory of
your career.”
And you could see early on that it would be
better to be on your own.
Markus: Yes…it’s like the manager who
told me I should change the script and make
it a dude (it was written about a woman).
It’s like he’s not wrong.
He’s not right.
It’s just a difference.
People get caught up in right and wrong, blame,
this and that.
It’s like there is stuff that is and there
is stuff that isn’t.
Like whatever perception you put on it is
your perception.
I get way more accomplished with that mindset
then trying to figure out right and wrong,
this and that.
I like this.
I think this works.
I think this proceeds in a manner that would
be entertaining to millions of people.
What do you think?
I think it should be like this, this, this,
and this.
Okay?
What do you think?
“I kinda dig it.
I think you can make some tweaks and make
it even cooler.”
“What are your tweaks?”
“Those sounds really cool.”
“Okay!”
“We should work together.”
That’s all I think it comes down to.
Now if it’s not a fit, it’s not a fit.
It’s like anything else.
It’s like friends, it’s like dating, it’s
like marriage.
If you’re constantly doing this, maybe it’s
not a fit.
Maybe…it’s not a fit.
Maybe there is a better way of getting your
work seen…heard…done.
Tyler Perry was homeless trying to figure
it out.
Couldn’t get anything going.
He started turning his scripts into plays.
Now he is sitting on top of an empire.
He’s worth hundreds of millions of dollars
doing whatever he wants to do.
I’m sure somebody told him “Well this
is dumb!
Tyler Perry you shouldn’t do that.”
Maybe they were right?
Maybe it could happen quicker?
Maybe they were wrong and it happened the
way it was supposed to?
So I just think it’s a matter of perspective.
I just think the most important thing is for
you as a writer to know who you are as a writer
to know who you are as a writer.
Like you have to know who you are and what
you do because they don’t.
You know what I mean?
They may have ideas about what the think it
could be.
And if that links up, awesome.
But you’ve got to know where you want to
go, what you want to do, how you want to do
it, the kind of thing you dig, the kind of
thing you don’t, what you are good at, what
you are not good at.
Because otherwise you get stuck in this battle
and you’ve got an agent or a manager or
an executive or a producer trying to get you
to do something that is not what you want
to do and it’s not good.
Film Courage: So not just the writer’s voice
but what they want to do with their career,
what projects they know they want to do?
Markus: Yes.
I think a writer should understand their identity
as a writer.
It doesn’t mean you can’t branch out and
do other things you know what I mean?
attack different genres and stuff.
But I think you should have a very clear understanding
of who you are as a writer, just as you should
have a very clear understanding of who you
are as a person.
You know, people are different and they have
different attributes and different value systems
and that’s who they are.
For better or for worse, that is who they
are but they know who they are when they know
who they are.
I think a writer is the same way.
This is what I do.
You know what I mean?
You watch the Shonda Rhimes show [Grey's Anatomy],
you know what you are getting.
And now even things that she doesn’t create
but things she executive produced, still feels
like the things that she wrote because she
knows what she does as a writer.
This is what I do, this is it.
Ryan Murphy who runs the gamut from American
Horror Story to Glee but there is still a
thread in there that lets you know that’s
Ryan Murphy.
That’s what he does.
The late Steven Bochco…that’s what he
did.
You know what I mean?
There is an identity, there is a through line
that comes through.
Film Courage: Stephen J. Cannell same thing.
Markus: All of the great show runners people
know.
Maybe they don’t know the title "show runner”
but these impresarios.
And in film, too.
Martin Scorsese who ran the gamut from GOODFELLAS
to THE AGE OF INNOCENCE.
Martin Scorsese, he knows who he is.
I think a writer should too.